just a girl hanging out between the nape
of a giraffe's neck and a robot with a
lightbulb head this is real performance
art Shia LaBeouf each [ __ ] hello guys my
name is Chris Helbig if you did not know
welcome to another it's grace video
League Golden Globe Awards have happened
over the weekend and I actually got
invited to one in the after parties suck
the dumbest sentence I used to make a
lot of videos reviewing red carpet
fashion and I thought let's do one today
so today I'm going to be reviewing the
Golden Globe 2015 red carpet fashion
Lupita Nyong'o how do I say her last
name I have no idea but I do know that
she is a beautiful flower she doesn't
have two nips on her chest she's got two
lips on her chest
hey tulips flowers what she's a
beautiful woman Emma Stone you what the
[ __ ] just being so cool and casual and
fashion-forward but just like still
relatable in some way also damn
shoulders you've been doing some
CrossFit why hasn't anyone made a
crisscross inspired fitness DVD and
called it CrossFit I know why cuz that's
a terrible idea
Jennifer Addison you look like a happy
Jersey bridesmaid reese witherspoon the
look on your own face this I'm bored by
myself too Katie Holmes here's the thing
I think Katie Holmes is getting more
beautiful every time I see a photo of
her and that might be the most sincere
sentiment in this entire video Surrey
has Katie's face got more angular since
you've been born Matthew McConaughey
this is Matthew McConaughey and not a
guy that auditioned for Sons of Anarchy
and didn't get it and has been living in
a terrible stilted reality ever since
Benedict Cumberbatch dafuq are you
did you come from christen way here's my
pitch Kristen wake you me emma stone but
come the next TLC just thrown it out
that I don't go chasing waterfalls
because water froze don't really move
they're pretty stagnant Claire Danes yes
you did buy out the beat section of
Michael's I am bedazzled by this and
also kind of solar perplexes by this
perplexed who knows like this dress that
joke was for overthought Heidi Klum is
there because reasons obviously and she
looks beautiful because that's her skill
set but then Cindy Crawford showed up
and was like uh uh Heidi Klum you can't
do this supermodel at an entertainment
award thing that no one totally knows
why is there thing anymore because I'm
here too now Salma Hayek did her hotel
not have an iron just like her dress I
look at this in my forehead gets
wrinkles Anna Kendrick I just wanted an
opportunity to show you on the red
carpet as a means for me to say can we
be friends to you me Emma Stone Kristen
Wiig the next Destiny's Child when they
had four members and they all got along
and all never broke up with each other
forever Helen Mirren
if this doesn't say [ __ ] you young [ __ ]
I don't know what does she looks amazing
I can only hope to be a quarter as great
as this photo exudes Jennifer Lopez we
get it this is what you do then you do
it really great is this the madame
tussauds wax figure of Jennifer Lopez or
is this really Jennifer Lopez we have no
idea
Keira Knightley Amy Poehler looks
fantastic I really love this dress very
much love the color let the pockets love
the whole of its to your napkin to wipe
my lipgloss off of your ass
that I just kissed to obey war this lord
have mercy
if ever my carpet photo I see of Lord
she's like just learned to smile for the
very first time but she team is really
great we do friends to you me Emma Stone
Anna Kendrick Kristen Wiig the new
version of dream that P Diddy put
together band remember what was that was
that called dream or they called like
fever dream there you go there was my
commentary on some of the Golden Globes
red carpet fashions I don't have a
rating system yet but I enjoyed making
this video leave me a comment letting me
know how I should rate things on this
channel now let me know what you think
because clearly I don't know don't
forget that I'm coming to the UK to do
some book signing so make sure you check
in down below to see which bookstores
I'm coming to and how you can come hang
out with me just get me